PRESIDENT TRUMP: IF THE PRESS
HAS NOT TREATED THESE INCREDIBLE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE DONE SUCH A
GREAT JOB, THEY HAVEN’T TREATED
THEM FAIRLY.
EVERYTHING WE DID, I WAS
CRITICIZED BECAUSE I WAS TOO
EARLY.
IF I WAITED LONGER, IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN, IF I WENT WAY EARLY
IF I WENT THREE MONTHS EARLIER I
WOULD HAVE BEEN CRITICIZED FOR
BEING WAY TOO EARLY, AND I
DON’T MIND BEING CRITICIZED, BUT
NOT WHEN THEY’RE WRONG.
NOT WHEN PEOPLE HAVE DONE A
GREAT JOB.
YES?
BRIAN:  SEE THE BRIEFING
YESTERDAY, THE BRIEFING
YESTERDAY BASICALLY WAS ALL-OUT
BRAWL BETWEEN THE PRESS AND THE
PRESIDENT, AND HAD NOTHING
TO DO WITH US.
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM WATCHED
TOO CHAIRMAN OF THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, REPUBLICAN
SOUTH CAROLINA.
SENATOR THE LOOKBACK SUNDAY WITH
THE NEW YORK TIMES PICKED UP BY
EVERY NEWS ORGANIZATION POINTED
ALL FINGERS AT BASICALLY THE
PRESIDENT FOR DROPPING THE
BALL AND NOT ACTING SOONER,
THE PRESIDENT FOUGHT BACK.
WHERE DOES THE TRUTH LIE?
>> WELL NUMBER ONE, MR.
PRESIDENT, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU’VE
DONE FOR THEM, AND THIS EFFORT
TO DESTROY TRUMP, NO MATTER THE
COST OF THE COUNTRY IS
GETTING A BIT OLD, AND IS
PISSING A LOT OF PEOPLE OFF.
THE PRESIDENT MADE FOUR REALLY
IMPORTANT DECISIONS TO SAVE
AMERICAN LIVES.
NUMBER ONE, HE SHUTDOWN TRAVEL
TO CHINA AND EUROPE IN A WAY TO
KEEP HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE BEING INFECTED.
HE DECLARED A NATIONAL EMERGENCY
TO GIVE THE COUNTRY THE TOOLS TO
FIGHT BACK, AND THAT WAS A MAJOR
DECISION, AND HE REJECTED THE
MENTALITY OF LETTING IT RUN
RAMPANT THROUGH THE COUNTRY AND
PEOPLE BUILD UP IMMUNITY A
COUPLE MILLION PEOPLE WOULD HAVE
DIED IF THAT HAD BEEN THE CASE
AND FINALLY, I THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING THE PRESIDENT
HAS DONE IS UNLEASHED THE
PRIVATE SECTOR IN TESTING
AND TRYING TO DEVELOP DRUGS BY
GIVING FDA WAIVERS FOR THERAPIES
AND VACCINES TO SPEED UP THE
PROCESS, SO I THINK THE
PRESIDENT HAS MADE REALLY
HARD CALLS WELL, AND WE’RE GOING
TO BE WELL BELOW THE 100,000
MINIMUM EXPECTED, AND IT’S DUE
TO HIS LEADERSHIP AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WORKING
TOGETHER.
AINSLEY: WHAT DID YOU THINK
ABOUT THAT TIMELINE?
I’VE NEVER SEEN A BRIEFING AND I
DON’T KNOW IF YOU HAVE, WHERE
THE PRESIDENT PUT TOGETHER AN
ENTIRE, CAN YOU HEAR ME?
SENATOR?
>> YES.
AINSLEY: OKAY, SO WHAT DID YOU
THINK OF THAT VIDEO THAT HE PUT
TOGETHER?
A TIMELINE OF THE JANUARY TRAVEL
BAN AND THEN PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA
SAYING THIS IS RIDICULOUS HE’S
GOING TOO FAR, YOU HAD BIDEN
SAYING XENO-PHOBIA AND THEN
ANOTHER SOUND BITE OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP IN FEBRUARY AND THEN
ANOTHER ONE IN THE MEDIA,
CRITICIZING HIM, AND NOW THE
MEDIA CRITICIZING HIM FOR
NOT DOING ENOUGH, SO I
THOUGHT THAT WAS PRETTY SMART ON
HIS PART, AND THEN HE ALSO
INCLUDED SOUND BITES OF THE
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK AND
GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA WHO ARE
BOTH DEMOCRATS PRAISING HIM.
>> WELL NUMBER ONE, WE’RE GOING
TO HAVE AN ELECTION IN NOVEMBER
BUT PEOPLE ARE DYING RIGHT NOW,
AND THIS PRESIDENT IS DOING
EVERYTHING HUMANLY POSSIBLE TO
WORK WITH ANYBODY THAT WILL WORK
WITH HIM.
DO YOU KNOW WHEN IMPEACHMENT
ENDED?
FEBRUARY 6.
WE VOTED TO ACQUIT THE PRESIDENT
AND DEMOCRATIC LEADERS WHO ARE
CRITICIZING THE PRESIDENT NOW
WANTED TO EXTEND THE TRIAL FOR
WEEKS TO CALL MORE WITNESSES
JOE BIDEN CRITICIZED PRESIDENT
TRUMP WHEN HE INVOKED THE
CHINESE TRAVEL BAN.
HE’S TRYING TO REWRITE HISTORY,
NOT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I DO BELIEVE THAT THE PRESIDENT
’S BIGGEST DECISION
WAS STOPPING TRAVEL FROM CHINA
AND EUROPE, DECLARING A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY SO WE COULD TAKE THE
FULL RESOURCES OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND PUT
THEM INTO PLAY HERE, AND WAVING
A LOT OF RULES AND REGULATIONS
SO THAT WE CAN GET VACCINES AND
DRUG THERAPIES HOPEFULLY BY THIS
FALL OR  LATE SUMMER, SO
WE’LL HAVE AN ELECTION OVER ALL
THIS BUT YOU GOT TO REMEMBER THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ON FEBRUARY 6
TO STAY IN SESSION TO GET MORE
WITNESSES.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
CRITICIZING.
STEVE: YEAH, NO KIDDING.
YOU KNOW, SENATOR, AFTER THE
PRESIDENTIAL DIRECTIVE ABOUT
PEOPLE STAY-AT-HOME FOR PRETTY
MUCH THE ENTIRE MONTH OF APRIL,
THERE ARE NOW MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE OUT OF WORK.
THEY ARE TRYING TO FILE FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
THROUGH THEIR STATES.
I WAS TALKING TO THE KANSAS
STATE SECRETARY OF LABOR, AND
SHE AND HER TEAM EXPLAINED TO ME
THAT NORMALLY, IN A WEEK, KANSAS
MIGHT PROCESS 1,300 UNEMPLOYMENT
CLAIMS.
NOW, IT’S 55,000 A WEEK, AND
THEY’VE HAD TO QUADRUPLE THE
CALL CENTER, AND THEY’RE
TRYING TO GET IT ON THE WEBSITE
BUT PEOPLE HAVE BEEN TRAYING FOR
WEEKS AND THEY STILL HAVEN’T
BEEN ABLE TO FILE FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT AND I KNOW
THAT IS ONE OF YOUR MAIN
CONCERNS.
>> YEAH, IN SOUTH CAROLINA, WE
HAD A 4,100% INCREASE IN
UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS, 85,000 LAST
WEEK AND A NORMAL WEEK IT’S
ABOUT 2,000.
OUR UNEMPLOYMENT SYSTEM IS
WORKING PRETTY WELL HERE.
WE’VE GOT MAJOR PROBLEMS LIKE
EVERYBODY ELSE WITH THE VOLUME,
BUT WE’VE PROCESSED 180,000
CLAIMS.
THE SMALL BUSINESS LOAN PROGRAM
THAT YOU TALKED ABOUT EARLIER IN
THE SHOW IS DESIGNED TO KEEP
SMALL BUSINESSES FROM GOING
BANKRUPT WHILE WE’RE IN
MITIGATION, AND IT’S DESIGNED TO
KEEP THEIR EMPLOYEES ON THE
PAYROLL.
HERE IS THE PROBLEM.
THE UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS IN
SOUTH CAROLINA ARE $23 AN HOUR
TO BE UNEMPLOYED, YOU’VE GOT A
LOT OF SMALL BUSINESSES TRYING
TO KEEP THEIR PEOPLE ON THE
PAYROLL PAYING $16 AND $17
AN HOUR, ONE PROGRAM IS UNDER
CUTTING THE OTHER AND WE’VE
GOT TO GET THAT FIXED.
BRIAN:  YOU DO, AND YOU HAVE TO
DO THE RATIO BETWEEN WHAT THEY
DO WITH THEIR MONEY.
I JUST DON’T UNDERSTAND WHY YOU
CAN’T GO BACK IN THERE AND JUST
FIX IT.
IT’S LIKE THE LAWMAKER THAT I
TALKED TO THAT SAYS THEY AGREE,
BUT NO ONE IS FIXING IT, BUT ON
ANOTHER NOTE, YOU GOT ANOTHER
REALITY CHECK LAST NIGHT, AS THE
TORNADO SLAMMED INTO YOUR
HOMETOWN OF SENICA, SOUTH
CAROLINA.
HOW IS EVERYBODY DOING?
>> WELL WE LOST ONE PERSON, A
MANUFACTURING PLANT,BORG WARNER,
AND IT GOT HIT HARD AND THE
PERSON GOT KILLED WORKING
THERE AT NIGHT AS A CONTRACTOR.
NORMALLY THEY BE RUNNING A THIRD
SHIFT AT THE PLANT WITH 200
PEOPLE AND IT’S JUST A BLESSING
FROM GOD THEY WERE NOT OPEN,
BECAUSE OF THE CORONAVIRUS, IT
WAS AN  EF-3 HURRICANE AT 3:30
IN THE MORNING I THOUGHT A TRAIN
WAS COMING THROUGH MY HOUSE, SO
MY HOMETOWN GOT HIT REALLY HARD.
WE LOST NINE PEOPLE IN SOUTH
CAROLINA TO THESE TORNADOES THAT
WENT ALL THROUGH THE STATE.
WE’LL GET THROUGH IT THE
GOVERNOR HAS BEEN GREAT BUT
WE’VE GOT TO FIX THIS LOAN
PROGRAM I DON’T MEAN TO CHANGE
TOPICS BUT THE 75/25 SPLIT NEEDS
TO CHANGE AND THERE ARE PEOPLE
APPLYING FOR THE SMALL BUSINESS
LOAN THAT REALLY ARE LIQUID AS
THEY CAN BE AND THEY’RE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF IT.
THE MONEY SHOULD BE FOR MAIN
STREET, AND SOME PEOPLE ARE
ABUSING THE SYSTEM.
BRIAN:  YOU CAN’T KEEP EMPLOYEES
IF THEY HAVE NO OWNER.
PEOPLE HAVE TO REMEMBER THERE
HAS TO BE AN OWNER AND EMPLOYEES
, NOT JUST EMPLOYEES.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT IT TAKES TO
GET THROUGH TO THESE PEOPLE.
AINSLEY: SENATOR, ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THANK YOU ALL.
AINSLEY: I THINK WE GOT TO GO.